so we already have a lot of experience
graphing things but let's review a
little bit so let's let me draw some
axes here so that's my y-axis and then
this is my x-axis that's my x-axis and
I'll just leave it a little bit so let's
say that's x equals 1 2 3 and then on
this axis I'm going to go up to 9 and
you'll see why in a second so let's say
this is 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 so i just
multiply it I just labeled all the
multiples of 3 I could have labeled more
than that so that's fairly standard at
least the first quadrant of the
coordinate plane and I let's grab some
function so I could graph a linear
function I could graph y is equal to X
what's that going to look like well when
X is 1 Y is 1 when x is 2 y is 2 when X
is 3 y is 3 and it's going to look like
this we are going to get a line that's
what we call it a linear function so
we're going to get a line like this in
any linear function if I did y is equal
to 2x and I would just have a steeper
slope if I added some number here say
plus 2 then I would have the steeper
slope and I would shift it up by two so
we've already seen that those are all
linear functions so let me just leave it
as y equals x / I guess arguably the
simplest linear function I guess y
equals a constant would be pretty simple
as well now let's also plot a quadratic
or let's just plot y is equal to x
squared and that's actually why i went
up to 9 here because when x is 0 Y is 0
when X is 1 Y is 1 when x is 2 y is 4 so
why y is for and when X is 3 y is 9 so
it would be right right over here and so
the graph of y equals x squared on this
on these axes is going to look something
like this and we've seen this multiple
times before
it's going to look something like that
we're we're used to recognizing this as
a quadratic and we're used to
recognizing a line as a linear function
that same green color but now I want to
do something interesting I want to
switch it up a little bit I want to
graph these same two functions but
instead of having a linear y axis I'm
going to have a I'm going to have a
y-axis that grows as a power of two I
guess you could say I'm going to have a
quadratic y axis so let me draw that
what am I talking about so let's say
let's say that my best attempt to draw
it all right roughly the same size and
on the x-axis I'm still going to just go
to three so the x-axis so that's 0 and
then I have one and then I have to and
then i have three but on the y-axis i'm
actually let me actually we do label it
like this so label it like this but
instead of this just being 1 i'm going
to say this is 1 squared which is of
course still 1 and instead of this being
too i'm going to say this is 2 squared
so this is going to be four instead of
saying this is 3 i'm gonna say this is 3
squared this is 9 so notice this isn't
this isn't this isn't the y-axis I each
each my each of my tick marks aren't
growing linearly they're growing
quadratically and I could even do the
tick marks in between instead of this
being 0 point 5 I could say this is
going to be 0 point 5 squared which is
0.25 instead of saying that this is 1.5
I could say that this is going to be 1.5
squared or 2.25 instead of saying that
this is 2.5 I could say this is 2.5
squared or 6.25 so once again if I go if
I go a certain distance if I go to
certain distance in this I'm not
increasing by the same amount when i go
from when i go from when i go from from
the bottom to hear i'm increasing by 1
when i go from here to here I
increasing by five when I go from here
to here I am increasing by 3 i'm used by
1 i'm increasing by 3 i'm increasing by
five so each each incremental hash mark
i'm increasing by more and more and more
and so this right over here this y-axis
is no longer linear this is now a i
guess you could say this is a quadratic
or it's growing as a power of 2 or of
each hash mark we're taking the square
of which hash market is instead of just
saying instead of just counting the
hashes now what's interesting is what
happens when we plot these functions on
this new coordinate plane word in the
x-axis I'm still linear but in the
y-axis I'm growing as a power of 2 so
let's try it out it this is actually
pretty interesting I encourage you to
pause the video and see if you could
work through it on your own all right so
let's plot let's actually first plot y
equals x squared because it's actually
going to be a little bit more
straightforward well when x is 0 0
squared is still 0 when x is 0 point
five what's point 5 squared well it's
0.25 so it's going to be right there
when X is 1 what's 1 squared well it's
one when X is 2 what's 2 squared well 2
squared is 4 when X is 3 what's 3
squared well 3 squared is 9 so it looks
when I plot this quadratic and I had a
quadratic scale for my y-axis what just
happened well the graph of y equals x
squared now looks like a line y equals x
squared what kind of Voodoo am i doing
well remember this scale is no longer
linear that's why this now looks like a
line what's interesting or even more
interesting is what happens when if I
try to plot y equals x when x is 0 Y is
0 when X is 0.25 y is going to be 0.25
and I'm just random I'm just sampling
some points that are going to be easy
for me to pick out when X is 1 Y is 1
when x is 2 y is 2 so 2 is going to be
someplace around here when X is 3 y is 3
kill me so too might be around here when
X is 3 y is 3 so what is this graph look
like so it's going to look something
like this so the graph of the graph of y
equals x on this axis or on this
coordinate plane where I don't know
where I no longer have a linear y axis
this is starting to look at least if I
were thinking on linear in on a linear
scale this looks like the graph of y
equals square root of x but it's not
this is the graph of y equals x this is
a linear function it doesn't look like a
line anymore because I no longer have a
linear y scale so hopefully this opens
up your brain to thinking about wow
there's all sorts of scales you can have
and it's not a typical it's not unusual
to have logarithmic scale exponential
scale these things are actually done and
in general if you change your scale if
say this X Gail stays linear and on your
Y scale you're now growing quadratics
well then are you growing quadratically
then quadratics are going to look like
lines on this on this coordinate if you
grew this if you grew this
logarithmically then logarithmic
functions are going to look like lines
so whatever whatever type of scale you
do in the vertical axis as long as you
keep the X scale linear then that type
of function is going to look like a line
on this kind of wacky coordinate plane